Gerard Neufeld funeral home is a
family-run business and it's overwhelmed
the bodies of kovat 19 victims small
groups yes keep coming if you just give
me a call to let me know when you're
coming because we are a little busy and
I want to make sure if somebody is here
to sit down and speak with you properly
the caskets are closed
the chairs largely bereft of mourners
but the work doesn't stop the man is
just unfortunately a lot of debts all at
the same time so we're trying to manage
services for all the families in a
proper way whatever they want to do so
and it's just a lot of families all at
the same time so we're trying to get fit
in schedules trying to keep track of
who's you know which day which families
better go and go from there just down
the road is Elmhurst Hospital the center
of the outbreak where doctors say the
situation is apocalyptic crazy ailing
people are unfortunately passing away in
big numbers and because they live in
this area and I'm the only funeral home
left in this area they're coming to me
so so I'm trying to accommodate them the
best I can and every day yes yes I mean
we left the office last night and I
think we had about 12 services or so
scheduled and shortly after I left the
office within two hours I had three more
services and then this morning as soon
as we came in we put on three or four
more services so that's what's happening
and it's only 12 o'clock
Robert Lugo has just lost his
grandmother Anna isolated in her
suffering her family now robbed of the
chance to grieve together my grandmother
died alone
those that my grandma she died alone we
didn't even get to say bye yeah and I
understand that part of the death
process but she was zero she was in the
hospital she was feet away we couldn't
even see how we couldn't touch to talk
to her we couldn't even give her like
that boost of morale to say hey you know
you're gonna come out of this we need
you to come out of it it's late there
was nothing what would you say to those
people who don't think coronavirus is a
serious threat if you don't think that
it's a serious threat Here I am I lost
my grandmother and I'm in the mess of
less than a week her family had just
celebrated her 80th birthday they call
her the glue now they to a sick because
she was exposed to the virus they also
became a source of the virus and half of
our family member right now are in
quarantine because they tested positive
with collective mourning forbidden and
traditional rituals removed death is
marked by a drive through crematories
really aren't letting anybody in the
cemeteries are limiting it for the most
part to people staying in their cars and
just watching the burial from the
graveside Joe now negotiates at the
gates carrying candles for the families
that can't sometimes when it's so brief
it almost leaves them still feeling
Hollow like you know what just happens
they don't have enough time to process
it
hey it's heartbreaking it's really sad
Joe and his father of vulnerable
handling infected bodies but they keep
going determined to offer dignity to
those who left this world without a hand
to hold